five-month-old garrett was born in the
middle of a pandemic while his mom
maureen gardner was unemployed
she says keeping up with his growing
needs can be a challenge but she has
reason not to worry a total lifesaver
thanks to an unexpected economic
lifeline from an experimental program
called the bridge project which is
giving her one thousand dollars a month
this is the only income that i receive i
receive no public assistance i do
receive food stamps so i'm able to feed
myself
but other than that you know
i kind of rely on this money to pay my
cell phone bill
keep the internet on
by clues he's a growing baby and he's
like growing really fast
in new york city one in four children
under the age of three live in poverty
the program is helping 100 families
whose average yearly income is 14
thousand five hundred dollars
well below the federal poverty line
the foundation behind the project argues
the financial support to the families
will yield long-term benefits for the
children we really wanted it to be done
so that we could study this over time
and really understand what the effect of
this money is
on everything from mental health to food
security to housing security to really
importantly how the baby is developing
and reaching their milestones
it's a concept known as guaranteed
minimum income advocates say cash with
no strings attached is the best way to
help families out of a cycle of poverty
and experiments like the one here in new
york are happening all across the
country to prove it but what would be a
change of social policy here in the
united states is actually quite common
in europe and canada
last july millions of american families
got an unexpected cash infusion from the
government in the form of the child tax
credit meant to help with expenses like
child care during the pandemic but
congress has yet to reauthorize it this
year if you look at how the money was
spent a large majority of it went to up
to middle and upper middle class people
and from that vantage point it's not a
very efficient policy it's like you
shouldn't have to give a lot of money to
richer people to help poor people still
advocates say there's growing evidence
families put the money to good use
gardner's payments are guaranteed for
three years regardless if i do start
working regardless of how much i make
i will still be able to receive the
thousand dollars to care for my child
giving her the time and security to
better plan for their future
kristin salumi al jazeera new york